could you describe what a ketogenic diet
is for anyone who isn't familiar with it
so it turns out the ketogenic diet was
actually developed to stop seizures and
it was developed to mimic the fasting
State because the doctors at that time
knew that fasting can stop seizures the
problem with fasting is that if you fast
for too long you starve to death and
that's not a very good treatment so Dr
Russell Wilder invented the ketogenic
diet with the purpose of trying to trick
the body into thinking that it was
fasting when it really wasn't but
providing enough nutrition so that the
person was not starving and even so that
young children could grow and thrive on
a ketogenic diet but he wanted to see if
it could stop seizures and lo and behold
it worked and it's widely used as an
epilepsy treatment